hi today i'd like to
talk about breath
the um it doesn't matter what corner of
the world
we live in and whether you're doing a
a martial art or or not
yoga has talks about breath
chi kung tai chi chinese talk about the
breath
so to my knowledge
every single martial art or
human being is breathing
the meditation system
it also talks about the breath
following the breath watching the breath
so the breath is a far more important
thing
than we may sometimes realize
we do it automatically the moment i
start talking about it
in a class to anyone you can see they
start
taking note of their breath and how it's
going in and how it's going out
and this is a short film on
how we should develop the breath and
make the breath
work our whole body
as if like a pendulum
and the pendulum of the breath
if it instructs the the body throughout
the body
we can either use it for slow motion
or we can use it for
a quicker emotion
the my patreon site
is designed to help each individual
find what i consider secrets
points of interest that
i don't freely give away because
take it's taken me nearly 50 years to
discover these things travel the world
listening to various different
masters not just aikido
tai chi meditation but
people who are trying to practice
and show people well-being
how to look after one's body
so this is really for anyone who wants
to
care for their body and it doesn't
matter about the past
how you've abused it or not abused it
or how you've taken time for yourself
or not taking time for yourself
it all to me ends up with the breath
your breath can tell you if you're
stressed
if you're relaxed and calm
it can help you in so many ways but it
can make your body
more efficient your blood more refined
and
and this should hopefully bring you
well-being throughout your whole body
if your body isn't completely
functioning as
one would hope or you've got a
disability
an illness then the breath can still be
used
because without the breath you wouldn't
be alive and
listening to me now
so if you're interested
in knowing more about the breath it
doesn't
just because our knowledge tells us it's
in
our lungs here
it doesn't just stop there we couple the
instruction of the mind and we tell
the body that it must work to the rhythm
of the breath
and by going deeper into the body
and starting to experience the breath
in other parts of your body
um you may not even know but the
refreshness
that it will give you and the well-being
like anything takes time if you take
vitamins
they're not going to work straight away
they take time
even medication from the health service
most of them are not instant the ones
for
chronic illnesses usually start to work
out
after a few weeks it's like a drip feed
slowly going into the body to
mask it or help it or even repair it
and so this is what i hope that we can
do with the breath
and also the breath can
tell you how to be more sensitive to
understanding your own body
so if you're interested please subscribe
to my
patreon site the link is below with the
other
links and
perhaps just try it for a month see what
you think
five pounds you can watch the videos and
listen to
my explanations if you want a one-to-one
around the world
this can also be arranged on any subject
that i do we can have our one-to-one
meetings
for not a great deal of money
and each month we can go step by step
whether it be aikido tai chi
meditation lazy yoga
that's what i call it because i teach
one
movement at a time so it doesn't stress
you or exhaust you
so thank you for listening and
remember the breath is a very important
thing
and i will be taking it step by step
helping you to build
your body up the well-being
and if it's any art that you're doing
you do need to know how to call upon the
breath
to call upon the body so that it all
works as one
the thing people talk about is
sometimes superhuman power
they had superhuman power did you see
what they performed with their body
this is all done through long-term
exercise
but also the breath without the breath
the body cannot do these vigorous
magical things
and bring calling forth the breath
and all the muscles tendons ligaments of
the body
one can perform an amazing feat
of power rather than
strength is normally comes from muscles
but power comes from your whole being
but driven by the breath
thank you for listening